when she's not acting Shields finds time
to pursue other creative projects and
enjoy the perks of Fame aside from being
an avid photographer climber and
Bookworm she's also a budding
fashionista she first got a taste for
fashion while making appearances during
the many Hunger Games press tours and
film premieres wearing gowns and outfits
designed by some of the world's top
designers however her fashion Pursuits
didn't stop there since then Shields has
been a regular fixture at New York
Fashion Week following in the footsteps
of co-star Jennifer Lawrence in 2016 she
was the youngest front row New York
Fashion Week attendees Shields described
her personal style saying it's kind of a
mix of things a lot of it is vintage I
always have loved wearing vintage
clothing I would definitely say kind of
vintage grunge but also sometimes that
very chic classic look is something that
I like to throw in